for decades ethnic groups have on
average scored significantly differently
on IQ tests according to psychology
professor Richard hare whom you
interviewed on your channel YouTube
there is no scientific consensus on the
causes of these average differences in
IQ test scores yet according to hair
psychologists do generally agree that
general intelligence exists that IQ
measures it well and in a non culturally
biased way that IQ is highly predictive
of success in educational and
professional terms and that for decades
ethnic groups have on average scored
significantly differently so assuming
this is true should we talk about it Sam
Harris raised this question in a podcast
conversation with Charles Murray
some argue that we should not talk about
this as doing so could fuel the racial
supremacist movements that you mentioned
with potentially horrific consequences
others mainly on the intellectual dark
web and to a very limited extent in
academia think we should talk about this
topic because average differences in IQ
scores have existed for decades they may
have played a role in generating the
disparate educational and professional
outcomes that we observe and care about
and thus that we cannot properly analyze
these disparate outcomes unless we do
talk about this subject openly
geneticist David Reich recently argued
in the New York Times that if scientists
do not openly discuss the biological
basis of race pseudo scientists could
fill the vacuum with dangerous
consequences furthermore you professor
Peterson are highly critical of the
oppression narrative that permeates
segments of the Academy and activists
left and knowledge about average
differences in IQ scores between ethnic
groups while tough to assimilate could
puncture this narrative so the question
is what is your view on all that I've
just said Jesus you guys already did
take a long time to prepare these
questions didn't
all right so when I went to Harvard I
came from the Gil and I had spent a lot
of time with my adviser there and a
research team that he had trying to
understand the genesis of antisocial
behavior and among adolescents mostly so
well as kids as well
antisocial behavior is very persistent
so if you have a child whose conduct
disordered at the age of four the
probability that they will be criminal
at the age of fifteen or twenty is
extremely high it's unbelievably stable
it's a very dismal literature because
you see these early onset aggressive
kids and and it's persistent and then
you look at the intervention literature
and you throw up your hands because no
interventions work and believe me
psychologists have tried everything you
could possibly imagine and a bunch of
things that you can't in order to
ameliorate that so we're really
interested in trying to understand for
example if you're antisocial by the age
of four then there isn't an intervention
that seems to be effective so and the
standard penological theory is really
quite horrifying in this regard because
what you see is that male aggression
Peaks around the age of 15 and then it
declines fairly precipitously and and
and sort of normalizes again by the age
of 27 and standard phenological Theory
essentially is this cold-hearted it's
like if you have a mult if you have
someone who's a multiple offender you
just throw them in prison till they're
27 then they age out of it and that's
all there is to it that's that's what
we've got now there's some downside to
that because there's a corollary
literature that suggests that the worst
thing that you can do with antisocial
people is to group them together which
is what we do in prisons so so that's a
whole mess anyways one of the things we
were doing was trying to see if there
might be cognitive predictors of
antisocial behavior and so we used this
battery of neuropsychological tests that
was put together at the Montreal
Neurological Institute took about 11
hours to administer and hypothetically
assess prefrontal cortical function we
computerized out reduced
to about ninety minutes and then assess
antisocial adolescents in in Montreal
and found out that they did show
deficits in the problem-solving ability
that we associated with with prefrontal
ability when I got to Harvard I thought
well that's interesting we could use the
neuro psych battery to predict negative
behavior perhaps we could use it to
predict positive behavior so I thought
well what if we turned the neuro psych
battery and over and thought well can we
predict grades for example because you
know that's a decent thing to predict so
we ran a study we ran a study that
looked at Harvard kids University of
Toronto kids line workers at a Milwaukee
factory and managers and executives at
the same Factory and what we found was
that the average score across these
neuropsychological tests they were kind
of like games they were game-like you
know so in one in one test you had there
were five lights in the middle of the
screen and a box was associated with
each light and you had to learn by trial
and error which box was associated with
with each light that was one of the
tests so we took people's average score
across the tests because they seemed to
clump together into a single structure
you can do you can find that out
statistically if you take a bunch of
tests you can find out how they clump
together statistically by looking at
their patterns of correlations and you
might get multiple clumps which is what
happens with personality research where
you get five or you might get a singular
clump which is what happens in cognitive
research and we got a single clump
essentially and then we were trying to
figure out if at the same time I was
reading the literature on performance
prediction and there's an extensive
literature on performance prediction a
lot of it generated by the Armed Forces
by the way indicating that IQ is a very
good predictor of long-term life success
and so here's that here's the general
rule if your job is simple which means
you do the same thing every day
then IQ predicts how fast you'll learn
the job but not how well you you do it
but if your job is complex which means
that the demands change on an ongoing
basis then the best predictor of success
is general cognitive ability
and and I learned that the general
cognitive ability test clumped together
into a single factor that's fluid
intelligence or IQ and then we didn't
know if the factor that we had found was
the same factor as IQ and it and we
still haven't really figured out whether
or not that was the case because it kind
of depends on how you do the analysis
but anyways I I got deeply into the
performance prediction literature and I
found oh well if you wanted to predict
people's performance in life there's
there's a couple of things you need to
know you need to know their general
cognitive ability if they're going to do
a complex job you need to know their
trait conscientiousness some of you
might have heard that rebranded as grit
in a very corrupt act by the way because
it's a good predictor of long-term life
success freedom from negative emotion
low neuroticism is another predictor but
it's sort of third on the hierarchy and
then openness to experience which is a
personality trait is associated with
with expertise in creative domains the
evidence that now I should tell you
there's such a complicated question I
should tell you how to make an IQ test
is actually really easy and you need to
know this to actually understand what IQ
is so imagine that you generated a set
of 10,000 questions okay about anything
it could be math problems they could be
general knowledge they could be
vocabulary they could be multiple choice
it really doesn't matter what they're
about as long as they require
abstraction to solve so they'd be
formulated linguistically but
mathematically would also apply and then
you have those 10,000 questions now you
take a random set of a hundred of those
questions and you give them to a
thousand people and all you do is sum up
the answers right from so some people
are gonna get most of them right and
some of some of them are gonna get most
of them wrong you just rank order the
people in terms of their score correct
that for age and you have IQ that's all
there is to it and what you'll find is
that no matter which random set of a
hundred questions you take the people at
the top of one random set will be at the
top of all the others and in it with
very very very high consistency so one
thing you need to know is that if any
social science claims whatsoever are
correct then the IQ claims are correct
because the IQ claims are more
psychometrically rigorous than any other
phenomena phenomenon that's been
discovered by social scientists now the
IQ literature is a dismal literature no
one likes it here's why here's an
example so here's our little here's a
fun little fact for you
for liberals and conservatives alike
because conservatives think there's a
job for everyone if people just get off
their asses and get to work and liberals
think while you can train anyone to do
anything it's like no there isn't a job
for everyone and no you can't train
everyone to do everything that's wrong
and here's one of the consequences of
that so as I mentioned the Armed Forces
has done a lot of work on IQ and they
started back in 1919 and the reason they
did that was because well for obvious
reasons say let's say there's a war and
you want to get qualified people into
the officer positions as rapidly as
possible or you'll lose so that's a
reason now the Armed Forces has
experimented with IQ test since 1919 and
in the last 20 years a law was passed as
a consequence of that analysis which was
that it was illegal to induct anyone
into the Armed Forces who had an IQ of
less than 83 now the question is why and
the answer was all of that effort put in
by the armed forces indicated that if
you had an IQ of 83 or less there wasn't
anything that you could be trained to do
in the military that wasn't positively
counterproductive now you got to think
about that a because the military is
chronically desperate for people right
there it's not like they're it's not
like people are lining up to be inducted
right they have to go out and recruit
and it's not easy and so they're
desperate to get their hands on every
body they can possibly manage and then
especially in wartime but also in
peacetime but then there was another
reason to which was the Armed Forces was
also set up from a policy perspective to
take people in the underclass let's say
and train them and move them up at least
into the working class or maybe the
middle class so there's a policy element
to it too and so even from that
perspective you could see that the
military is desperate to bring people in
but yeah well with an IQ of 83 or less
it's not happening okay so how many
people have an IQ of 83 or less
10% now if that doesn't if that doesn't
hurt you to here then you didn't hear it
properly because what it implies is that
in a complex society like ours and one
that's becoming increasingly complex
there isn't anything for 10% of the
population to do all right well what are
we gonna do we're gonna ignore that
we're gonna run away from that and
believe me we have every reason to or
we're gonna contend with the fact that
we need to figure out how it is how it
is how it might be possible to find a
place for people on the lower end of the
general cognitive distribution to take
their productive and and worthwhile
place in society and that isn't just
gonna be a matter of dumping money down
the hierarchy because giving people who
have nothing to do money isn't helpful
it doesn't work it's not that simple
well so that's kind of an answer to the
question of whether or not we should
deal with the with IQ forthrightly it's
like if you can find a flaw in that
logic like just go right ahead it's not
like I was thrilled to death to discover
all of this by nose by no stretch of the
imagination was that the case so so what
so IQ is reliable invalid that's the
first thing it's more reliable and valid
than any other psychometric test ever
designed by social scientists by a
factor of about three that's fact number
one fact number two is it predicts long
term life outcome at about 0.3 0.4 which
leaves about 85 percent 70 to 85 percent
of the story unexplained but it's still
the best thing that we have well it's
also the case that in places like Great
Britain when IQ tests were first
introduced they were actually used by
the Socialists and they were used to
identify poor people who had potential
cognitive potential and to move them
into higher Institutes of higher
education so there's an upside you know
a social upside as well ethnic
differences
this is something you can't say anything
about without without immediately being
killed so I'm hesitant to broach the
topic but I'll tell you one thing that I
did in the last week that's relevant to
this so though and this just shows you
how complex the problem is first of all
we should point out that race is a very
difficult thing to define because racial
boundaries aren't tight right so and so
when you talk about racial differences
in IQ you you're faced with the thorny
problem of defining race and that's a
big problem from a scientific
perspective but we'll leave that aside
and I wrote an article this week
somebody stood up at one point one of my
talks and veiss bless their hearts took
this particular question and used it as
an indication of the quality of the
people who are my so-called followers
and by the way the quality of my
so-called followers is pretty damn high
and you can find that out quite rapidly
just by going looking at the YouTube
comments which are head and shoulders
above what the standards said of YouTube
comments I can tell you that so someone
asked me they're both the Jewish
Question right and the the implication
it was actually someone Jewish and the
implication was that Jews are
over-represented in positions of
authority and power and and I was had
just spoken for like an hour and a half
and you know this guy had an axe to
grind and I thought there's no goddamn
way I'm getting into this at the moment
and so I said I said I can't answer that
question but that's not a very good
answer so I wrote a blog post this week
and I said look here's the here's the
situation all right
Jews are over-represented in positions
of power and authority but then let's
open her eyes a little bit and think for
like two or three seconds and think hey
guess what they're also over-represented
in positions of competence and it's not
like we have more geniuses than we know
what to do with and if the Jews happen
to be producing more of them which they
are by the way then that's a pretty good
thing for the rest of us so let's not
confuse competence with power and
authority even though that's a favorite
trick of the radical leftist who always
failed to make that distinction well why
does this over-represent
you know kur because it does it also
there's also over-representation in
political movements including radical
political movements okay why
well answer one Jewish conspiracy okay
that's not a very good answer we've had
we've used that answer before alright
but but do we have an alternative well
here's an alternative the average
Ashkenazi IQ is somewhere between 110
and 115 which is about one standard
deviation above the population average
and so what that means is that the
average Ashkenazi / European Jew has an
IQ that's higher than 85% of the
population that's a lot higher now that
doesn't make that much difference in the
middle of the distribution okay but
geniuses don't exist at the middle of
the distribution they exist at the tails
of the distribution and you don't need
much of a move at the mean to produce
walloping differences at the tails and
the tails are important because a lot of
where we draw we draw exceptional people
from the exceptions right so here's an
example of the same thing most engineers
are male why because men are more
interested in things and women are more
interested in people and you might say
well that's socio-cultural it's like no
it's not and we know that because if you
stack up countries by their by their
egalitarian social policies which you
can do quite effectively and then you
look at the over-representation of men
in STEM fields the over-representation
increases as the countries become more
egalitarian so it's not socio-cultural
okay now men aren't that much more
interested in things than women it's one
standard deviation which is about the
same difference by the way between the
population norm and the Ashkenazi Jews
but if you're looking at the person the
one person in 20 or the one person in 50
who's most who's hyper interested in
things and thus likely to become an
engineer then most of them are men
here's another example of the same thing
men are more
aggressive than women now you might ask
how much an answer that is best place to
look at that is in Sweden where the
Galit Aryan policies have been laid out
for a long period of time and you can
you can get a more direct inference
about biology if you took a random man
and a random woman out of the population
and you had to bet on who was more
aggressive and you bet on the man you'd
be right 60% of the time so that's not
that much right it's it's deviates from
50/50 but it's not like ninety ten it's
60/40 okay so so what does that mean
well we got a tail problem here again
let's say that now you decide to go out
onto the extremes of aggression and you
identify the most aggressive one in a
hundred persons they're all men guess
who's in prison those people that's why
most of the people in prison are men and
so this is elementary part of the
problem in our society is that we don't
understand statistics we don't
understand that you can have relatively
small differences at the population
level that produce walloping
consequences at the tails of the
distribution okay so back to IQ one
final thing to say about IQ the ethnic
differences are difficult to dispense
with it's not easy to make them go away
you can say well the tests aren't
culture fair well here's a test of that
so imagine you you test Group A with an
IQ test and you test Group B with an IQ
test and then you look at their actual
performance in whatever you're
predicting if the test was biased
against ethnic group a then it would
under predict their performance and that
doesn't happen now you could say well
there's systemic bias in the performance
measures and the potential measures and
that's a possibility all right now one
other thing about that there's a real
danger in the ethnicity IQ debate and
they the danger is that we confuse
intelligence with value or that we
include we we confused
with ya with human value that's a better
way of thinking about it and one of the
things that we're going to have to
understand here is that that's a mistake
is that being more intelligent doesn't
make you a better person that's not the
case it makes me you more useful for
complex cognitive operations but you can
be pretty damn horrific as a genius son
of a bitch right it's morally neutral
and we also know that from the
psychometric data by the way there
doesn't seem to be any relationship
whatsoever between intelligence and
virtue and so if it does turn out that
nature and the fates do not align with
our egalitarian presuppositions which is
highly probable
we shouldn't therefore make the mistake
of assuming that if group a or person a
is lower on one of these attributes than
group B or person B that that is somehow
reflective of their intrinsic value as
human beings that's a big mistake